now you've got my my rainbow of a
diagram here I really really hope you
drew a diagram because good lord that's
a lot of geometry that's interacting
with itself and you have to put some
constructions on there and all that kind
of thing
now I sort of hoped you would go OK on
this because we proved this exact result
it has a name does anyone remember it's
the this is the satellite dish thank you
this is called you can see you can see
in here you see the angles that I've
marked right so this is the reflective
property of a parabola
it's what means that for a satellite
dish all the radiation coming down it
reflects up to the focus or for a set of
headlights on a car one light all goes
in random different directions but it
all goes forward or in this case upward
okay so we have proved this actual
property before but it was a while ago
so I certainly can't actually remember
all of the individual steps but at least
I knew I was getting out okay so I won't
labor all of the individual lines here I
will show this back to you when we're
done but let's just um go through the
major themes so explain why s P equals P
D see that word explained all right so
I'm expecting some kind of reasoning
from you it's only one mark so it
doesn't have to be an essay that's
that's all you really need to say okay
what what are we assessing here do you
understand what a parabola is and what
its relationship is with the focus and
the directrix that's all we're looking
for okay once you stayed that part -
that's also kind of a gimme we've we've
worked with this equation before it's
pretty easy to find because they say
show that and there's a mark there we
expect you to actually find what that
derivative is not that it's difficult
and then sum it into a point green form
that's not complicated okay right part
three stats is where stuff starts to get
a little more fun it's still not
complicated though because you have to
prove that PQ is perpendicular SD just
let me hide my working for a second just
you've just got to orient yourself
properly right look at where PQ is you
know what its gradient is look at where
s D is well you don't know its gradient
so you have to find it okay so you can
see what you're doing and that's why you
can see I go straight to finding the
gradient of s D okay quick question this
said according to you
where'd that come from but just in my
answer just seems to come from today
where does it come from yeah okay
fantastic so you can see that wait hold
on
do me PP yeah so Dee have a look at your
diagram Dee is vertically below P so
that means they share an x coordinate
yeah how do I get its y coordinate it's
on the directrix and everywhere on the
directrix y equals negative a so that's
where that comes from
you can pump it into your gradient
formula and then how'd you get it okay
have a look at this please don't worry
about writing all of this down but I
would encourage you to read it along
with my with your diagram actually I
haven't introduced any letters I've just
used the letters that they've got so
you've got to do some angle psalms you
have to take advantage of an isosceles
triangle which isosceles triangle is it
have a look P SD you know that one that
in part one you prove that the sides are
equal you were the one who proved that
there are saucily so we we didn't just
throw that in for fun we're through din
to give you a clue okay you've got to
use like isosceles triangle you've got
to do angle summer triangle again and
then you find that I just called a theta
so I didn't have to keep on writing the
letters okay but you didn't have to do
that so again I'll send it through to
you when you're done and I asked you to
skip five and six because four time just
so you actually had a reasonable amount
for that any questions about that proof
for the reflective property all right
yeah Russell yes you could yeah I just
did it for the sake of time because I
knew you were running out and I ran out
anyway okay how he faring all right so
we are currently on to question three I
only wanted to do one last question in
this one party okay now I'll admit this
question has a bit of a a bit of a rude
trick in it partly because you can see
it's in a topic like look at the
question question three it's all that
polynomials I asked you to skip most of
this question because we know
polynomials you actually know enough to
do all these questions but they're not
gonna be assessed in Wednesday's task
however I chose to leave this one in
here
because most of it doesn't require like
all the fancy polynomial stuff you've
learnt so far just a little bit okay so
you had to find the equation of the
tenant to this curve at that point
what's going on it's a cubic right so X
cubed minus X you can actually know
exactly what this I'll leave this color
you can know exactly what this looks
like right can you help me factorize
this thing what is it X take it out out
you get left with that and then you can
factorize again right what do you li get
left with X minus 1 X plus 1 your a
difference of squares so this is a very
simple cubic graph to draw I'll just
leave it there you're gonna get 1 2 3
intercepts so oh I missed but you get
the idea okay so this is what you're
getting and then they say hey I have a
tangent at some point and it's going to
intersect the graph somewhere else like
here and here so what's this something
else that's the question okay so what
did I do well you can see that I had to
find the equation of the curve first of
the credit other tangent I should say
you need a point which has been provided
you also need a gradient so you can see
what I've done
I had to differentiate wasn't
complicated and then here is your point
gradient whoops
form are you ok with that so I know it
looks like algebraic soup but it's just
substitution into a simple formula okay
I'll admit it looks like a bit of a
dog's breakfast there but I just have to
have a little faith it's gonna pan out
okay does anyone have any questions up
to that point okay now just like we saw
with Paul earlier when you want to find
points of intersection what do you do
between two curves what do you do you
have to solve simultaneously don't you
okay
so I've got this this curve here and
I've got the original one which gives
you this and you look at that and I
guess this is what Russell was talking
about when he said oh I just look at
this paper it was fun to begin with and
then I seems through the rest of it cuz
using the katifaq I don't want to do
this now this is where the trick comes
in and maybe you won't encounter a
question like
in your tests on Wednesday but there's a
good chance in the future you will okay
just have a look at this note I've jot
down on the right hand side this is a
cubic and we're not really used to
dealing with cubic polynomials right
we'll we'll get more comfortable with
them but we're really just the start so
what kind of babies when it comes to
this quadratics were really good at
handling okay but you probably got to
maybe at this point and then you were
like what do I do
there's no quadratic formula for this
guy there's a cubic formula but it's
disastrous you don't even know about it
so you need to take advantage of
something you know from polynomials x
equals T is a solution right we got the
question itself tells us that because
there's a point of intersection that
means that X minus T is a factor I say
that again if x equals T is a solution
or a zero it might be a better way to
say it in this context then X minus T
will be a factor okay now at that point
because you guys know polynomial
division you could have gone straight
for it you could divide the cubic
polynomial by X minus T and you'll get
the answer that I'm getting get down
here but I chose to do this without it
just to demonstrate to you yeah you
don't need to know how to do polynomial
division if you've got a rough idea of
what factors you'll expect okay so what
I did was something you might remember
from quadratics when you're factorizing
non monika odd radix you got that middle
term and you split it into pieces and
then you pair things up and that's
exactly what pans out here I know what
direction I'm heading in because I know
what factor I'm expecting at the end
this guy over here okay so once you do
that it actually falls out quite simply
I know it looks long but it doesn't take
a lot of thought it just takes some
patience okay once you get that you
factorize factorize factorize and then
you come down to here now when you look
at the area like oh there's two
solutions right but you already know one
of them the the x equals t solution
which comes from here so that's why you
must say the other solution comes from
here does that make sense
okay so after that you sub it in and
you're fine okay